welcome back to the new rock stars
debrief I'm Erik Voss joining me today
are philip molina and sam basher hello
this is Sam thank you for having me gang
and hello this is Philip thank for
having me fan having me I'm happy to
have well we finally got an official
Avengers end game synopsis to set for
you guys
plus some pics from Game of Thrones
Season 8 the final season and some
interesting theories about Star Wars
heaven oh I thought we'd go there
thought they didn't believe in heaven
interesting also it's a little Walking
Dead - yeah you guys have been asking
about an update about The Walking Dead
and our coverage our coverage we haven't
forgotten about you guys so we got a big
fun announcement for you guys coming
later in the video or the podcast we on
how you're getting this yeah speaking of
do remember that you can enjoy this as a
podcast again our faces you don't have
to deal with them a lot of you guys are
actually already doing it we've gotten
some really great feedback so far and
we're excited to keep going so get it
wherever you get your podcast so we
would extra love it if you got it on the
moa app because they're direct
supporters of our podcast so it's really
great thanks so much yeah alright let's
get started guys so here's the deal we
got an official synopsis for Avengers
endgame we were able to piece together
what the story might be we've made
several videos about what the story
might be but here is an official
synopsis released and this is what it
says after the devastating events of
Avengers infinity war the universe is in
ruins due to the efforts of the mad
Titan Thanos with the help of remaining
allies the Avengers must assemble once
more in order to undo that OSes actions
and restore order to the universe once
and for all no matter what consequences
may be in store now I still want to see
it despite that voice you just use I
think some people want to see it more
because of the voice is the answer our
surveys okay let's get to the analysis
here there's three words that I think
are important the rest throw them away
ignore them
yeah ampersand yeah any any prepositions
are useless undo and restore are the
first two okay so that's it's
interesting then the first confirm like
the og Avengers maybe getting involved
at some time travel or alternate
realities in order to bring back the
dusted I mean think undo restore like
undo it makes it sound like Photoshop
menu items
control-z Thanos is snap I think that's
right that's undo isn't it depends on if
you're on a PC or Mac apples the Carosi
be like the idea of undo makes it sound
like yep prevent we're going back before
this happened or in reality where this
hasn't happened and make it so that we
have like a clean slate as a result of
our actions yeah I mean it definitely
sounds like restore from backup right
which I haven't been saving the universe
right oh man I don't do everything by
hand the yeah that's it maybe there's a
simulated reality that were that were
hinting at right yeah control but yeah
time travel confirmed time travel
confirms it you threw out just I know
we've talked about the alternate reality
thing but you're like oh start a new
reality for these people and it's like
oh that's a nightmare because that means
that other ones still exist doing it
based on undoing restore but I want the
Cronenberg universe right yeah I wanted
to jump to every possible ramification
and consequence it is played out
somewhere and everyone dies in some
other timeline well there's also the
word consequences
some people are pointing out that
justice Thanos had to sacrifice Gamora
to get the soul stone the avengers may
need to sacrifice someone as well right
to prevent him getting well cuz
otherwise it's a sitcom right Avengers
is like friends and everything gets
reset at the end of every episode which
sounds like a fun show yeah yeah but but
yeah if they have the stakes of like hey
half the universe was destroyed and you
know that felt really bad like we should
keep something bad something there
should be lasting effects they can't
really
the whole thing I mean I think we're all
kind of guessing like all right so you
you give up an adventure
yeah oh there you go I mean I understand
that a story element but if you have
magic wishing stones that make you any
wish you want I feel like you try to
give it that you try to get the A+ and
not the a - or the b-plus I think it's
an a-minus to lose one person versus the
half of the universe of that well I
would say an a-minus is like hey I'll
give you back a quarter of the universe
like a 25% reduction was still available
I wouldn't give it an a-plus so many
Avengers just give one away or one out
of six ain't bad
you know it's interesting someone
brought this up to me that in infinity
war there's a whole ongoing conversation
between vision and Captain America where
Captain America said we don't trade
lives here we're not the business of
trading lives but maybe that could be
something that cap ends up having to
change the tune on or he says well we
don't give lives or we don't trade lives
but I will trade a life well Drake my
they pointed that out that he owed you
did that he's done that before yeah he
jumped on the grenade he's yeah drove
the Valkyrie into the ice and he's done
that over and over again so now it was
already kind of a double standard but he
was given a vision is that setting up to
his final solution yeah he's gonna throw
someone in jumping on the grenade again
also remind you guys saw that quote by
is it Stephen McFeely and so it's the
two writers check out my Instagram at
the marina you see a picture of me that
I obsess about with them yeah it was a
picture with them you almost name-drop
oh you forgot one yeah but they had a
quote recently that was like hey by the
by we're not just gonna do that thing
where Adam warlock shows up and just
fixes everything the characters you care
about are the ones that are gonna solve
it so I think that's even more
indication they're like okay so if it's
cap or Iron Man the ones we care about
basically then they're definitely gonna
be sacrificing himself in some way or
something like that so if you say
characters I care about does that mean
like Wolverine mr. fantastic Human Torch
and
Sherlock Holmes hey why not yeah Maude
Garrett
okay all this time oh yeah I think this
for me
settles to concerns that I had going
into endgame one concern being that it
would just be too easy that they they
wouldn't have any consequences that they
could just reset it they're like oh
they're all toys it's like in comics
sometimes where it's like oh no death
really has stakes
it sounds like hopefully there will be
stakes hopefully there will be some kind
of major price being paid either a death
or characters just being separated into
different timelines and now Cap'n and
Tony can't be in movies together who
knows
that's one concern the other concern I
had was that another thing that would
make it too easy being defined
intervention I don't want like a cosmic
force coming in I don't want a living
tribunal Oh eternity so make it worse is
my my break I'm down for like anything
can happen make things worse but the
make things better and solve it needs to
come from characters we already know and
yeah you know ideally not some sort of
device either works like oh my god the
undo er button right there is a Pixar
story artist named Emma Coates who is
great to follow on Twitter cuz she has
like a bunch of rules of storytelling
that she goes by and all a Pixar tries
to abide by and one of her quotes is
that accidents and coincidences can get
your character into trouble but they can
not get your character out of trouble so
like if yeah as Phillip said if they if
some kind of weird coincidental thing
can make a character's fates worse or
their situation worse or make more
trouble for them that's fine but they
should have to get out of the problem
themselves own ingenuity yeah look and
come into play as long as it's bad luck
yes yeah that's a much more condensed
version yeah also I want to get props to
Disney and Marvel for just keeping
everything as vague as possible going
into this I'm like yeah the whole like
quote with it like we're gonna try to
use the first 15 minutes to cut our
trailers maybe it may be like first 30
but it's like keep it the movie is a
surprise like the movies genuinely a
surprises it's one of the biggest it's
like the biggest blockbuster they've
done maybe on par with infinity war but
I like that we're kind of it we're being
cagey a little bit it for that to make
the movie extra special for the fans
that have been watching it for this long
so yeah I'm more with the first 15
minutes I mean we're talking like it
sound like the movie could be over three
hours that's not even like the first act
of the movie there
like even the first flat movement before
we move on to other news time for trivia
question oh yeah this is fun as always
we're gonna question the loser will have
to join our gif of shame community and
if you're listening on a podcast you'll
just have to follow us on Twitter to see
who lost and what how embarrassing it
looks for them to do this action but for
now here's our question Thanos is the
short form of the Greek word then that
tent Thanatos Thanatos thanks Sam which
means what okay all of our answers are
in the bucket at the end of the episode
we'll review what the correct answer is
but for now let's move on to some Game
of Thrones news Phillip what have you
heard about this so the diet the biggest
thing this week I guess is just these
Game of Thrones pictures that came out
if you click through them a lot of them
seem like they're kind of just
production stills that are you know that
kind of they have them pose before but
actually if you look a little closer
there are some details here worth
pointing out so we got over I analyze
the crap alright so first off we've got
jaime lannister here definitely just
farted you know it's in the darkness of
what seems to be wonderful so I think we
can imagine that he's completed that
journey to Winterfell
he looks pretty content so he's probably
is fighting on their side but also I
mean maybe he's looking at a frolicking
Brienne
Brina Brina birth oh yeah that's Reunion
anyway I mean look he's he's smitten
he's charmed snowing his own scent yeah
this is not the expression I would
expect Jaime to have coming back to
Winterfell right because this is his
first time meeting brand again after
them oh maybe that's see that as a
Content face if you're listening to a
podcast you just got kind of a smug
smile it's also the kind of face like oh
did not expect to see the sharing at the
party I thought you ran away
they're wearing the same thing what the
only like bad moment I ever think with
like besides Jamie being just kind of a
dick and the beginning like the first
season's awful person I always think
about like that one the funeral for for
Joffrey and it's like that weird scene
between him and yeah not good and that
besides that like it was on a good
trajectory I always forget that yeah he
kicked a kid out of a tower yeah we've
had to deal with those consequences for
the entire series yeah it's Margaery
remember every single character on Game
of Thrones has kicked a child out of a
tower other pictures uh we can kind of
fly through them but there's shots of
Varys who's wearing all black which I
just thought was interesting John's
there Sam's there science is a Danny
Arya Brian and Davos but the one I want
to focus on that well actually sorry
their clothing all just looks like
they're all dressed more for winter so
it seems like a lot of them are in the
North obviously hers come to Westeros
the converted characters but they I just
want to confirm do you guys think that
who do you guys think is where basically
who do you think has made it to
Winterfell the list of characters you
just said it sounds like they're all
going to be there at least for what
anyone weighing dark basically yeah yeah
I mean it sounds like winters settled
settled over all over Westeros right
because we saw the snow dropping on
King's Landing at the end of season
seven and we have seen some brief teaser
clips of Daenerys and her whole
entourage arriving at Winterfell right
so we can assume anyone who is on part
of Daenerys delegation will be there as
well sorry what I'm kind of like teasing
that is Cersei and her and her look a
lot of people think her look is kind of
like a heavier cloth and and darker it's
kind of similar but I didn't seem so
much like she traveled she does still
seem to be at King's Landing which would
make sense but the real thing that a lot
of people are debating and this isn't us
making this up this is people just based
on this picture they're saying she looks
pregnant and I could see it kind of
going either way but we do have to
remember that even though it's rude for
us to assume that we don't condone just
jumping in and saying hey she look
pregnant
I'm gonna remind us that that she said
that she was to Jamie and remember you
know there was a lot of like debate
about is she lying is she trying to
manipulate him I I mean if she is lying
if she is faking if she mean she could
do that pillow move he doesn't know that
is interesti-- development also sam
basher is 19
it's easier to get in line Six Flags
that baby shower free he didn't return
our cribs road injury
somebody could yeah this could be
confirmation that she is actually and
she wasn't lying about that it does and
also there there are issues with the
prophesy about how many children she
would have like a weird number
misalignment with the number of kids who
actually had so yeah it could be trying
to deal with that but then finally
there's this shot of Aria that I want to
check out so she's got needle here which
is great but and she's also got the
cat's paw dagger which is the famous
dagger that a little finger just had a
very storied history with but a couple
things you want to point out about her
first of all she's looking up kind of in
amazement
some people say maybe it's a dragon I
like to think it's a vigorously waving
hot pie yeah it's wonderful but actually
the most interesting thing to me is the
person behind her this is somewhat a
spelt figure but that was a joke
anything spoke and I'm trying to like
guess who that could be they've got this
long hair this dark look I'm throwing
out there maybe Drock and my god oh
really fascinating if you know the man
who can look like anyone suddenly gets
involved in though in this war and
decided to not change his appearance
might be awkward though it's like
inviting work friends well he didn't
leave things really well with or REI
just gonna walked away yeah is the last
time we saw him
I've seen if I'm thinking I think so
yeah and then are there any other
guesses you guys have I've seen the
Hound could be an option but again
that's why I said spelt once he had a
crazy summer
I'm actually really on board with that
with Japan I think that'd be interesting
just to kind of round out that story
maybe give them some it like any kind of
closure maybe I don't even know if I
need that for arias character but that
they were together for kind of ish two
seasons and on and off again throughout
like earlier seasons as well why not
round out that she's been with chicken I
feel like almost more than the Hound you
can correct me you will but like it
feels like that to me thinking back on
it
I'll have to rewatch the whole series
before premieres again but I would be
happy with that yeah Eric - any other
guesses oh I don't know I was gonna say
a Mormont
you know like didn't she like mage
Mormont but she's dead that's white
Lyanna Mormont is now the I'm just
saying cuz the hair it's not like
well-groomed it's just kind of like all
over this I was thinking maybe earlier
you also think maybe a wildling
oh yeah like maybe some other person or
just some kind of northern Lord or lady
or someone who's any other guesses at
what she's looking at I guess said
amazement I'm seeing a little glossed
over where she's like half listening or
somebody I'm a you know what I this
scene is probably seeing a dragon coming
to Winterfell for the first time that
seems sort of the best guess I'll throw
out there she's maybe studying John and
Danny right and the influence that Danny
is having over John yeah
final guess bran coming back from the
future via time-travel with the cool new
haircut she has no way to really a moat
what that feels like but it would help
against the White Walkers cool all those
guesses are equally valid but yeah those
are the pictures and if you guys see
anything there there might be like a
Tarly or someone back there anything
else just let us know and we if it's
worthwhile we'll dig in deeper but tweet
at us I mean if you see something that
we don't what else we got well we got
some Star Wars news this right so there
were some rumors going around that
episode 9 which is coming out in
December of this year will feature the
Knights of Ren and that they'll be
coming from a place called the beyond
now taking the first part of that that's
excite
to hear this rumor that the Knights of
Ren might come back they only showed up
really in that four stream in the force
awakens and then the last Jedi didn't
really address them at all so we thought
that they might just be done but now JJ
Abrams is coming back so we're like oh
maybe he will want to bring back this
this cool like piece of backstory this
mystery now again these are all rumors
this comes from a source called making
Star Wars and it's kind of like a I
don't want say gossip source or a gossip
column but they've been right about
things in the past that's why we're kind
of taking this seriously
but the this whole idea of the beyond is
what a lot of people have been asking
about what is it or where is it well
there's some theories that it could be a
place in the Outer Rim that's just some
kind of location that's unexplored or
the unexplored or the Unknown Regions
and that's just like a place where kylo
Ren sent them off to go investigate and
that's why they weren't in the force
awakens like in the main timeline or in
the last Jedi there's also some rumors
coming out that the Knights of Ren will
return from the beyond
and that the Beyond will also be a
source of some great threat that the
resistance in the first order have to
join forces to confront and battle again
rumors this is just kind of sounds like
broad plot movement that might happen in
episode 9 and also people are suggesting
that the Beyond might be some kind of
like dimension of force energy that
could be like harmful to both sides
because the force is something that like
goes both ways essential there's a light
side and a dark side some people are
also suggesting the beyond could be a
form of like force heaven like this
could be the place where all the force
ghosts go and hang out when they're not
visiting Luke or younger Jedi who are
still alive it doesn't sound very
threatening if that's the case unless
there's some kind of like if it's some
kind of like neutral afterlife maybe
maybe there could be some kind of like
big threat and that in that sense and
then the word Beyond has showed up in
legends and in the EU before there's
this group called acolytes of the beyond
from the aftermath books they're like
collectors of darkside artifacts they
they were dealing with like Vader's old
lightsaber so that could maybe the word
Beyond could have been inspired and that
way you know they do take some pieces of
things from legends
it but they have been up to this point
not really focused on adapting specific
storylines and characters from legends
it's more like they'll include them as
Easter eggs and and character names and
things like that so what do you guys
think I think that my like giddy
childhood brain is like ooh
the first ghost we got Yoda and
everybody in their same place and that
sounds like awful have what I actually
try to picture like what it would be
like and you were there and you were
there like it actually I'm hoping it's
not land of the force ghosts mm-hmm
but yeah otherwise I think it would be
cool if it's some sort of like you know
what's on the other side of a black hole
or something and just some sort of like
place that kills you just to transfer
into it or something hmm personally I
kind of hope they don't use but beyond
because Star Trek did that so it's like
they've they already got that weird
conversation within later yeah dumb
brain idea first is that that's where
the Star Trek universe is they come over
we get a crossover in the next movie
boom there does it some idea our idea is
that the Knights of Ren have been out
training and recruiting I would really
like that idea because it's like there's
so few people using the force and all
these movies I just want like Lana I the
the part of the prequels I liked is that
they're just so many yes I love that
part of it and to have like such a
strong like Sith army coming in like I
know there's probably reasons why that
can't happen I jumped I'm not gonna get
into that but um I like the idea of them
coming back with like a bigger
recruitment of younger sis wielders yeah
however they're technically Sith but you
know I don't think so brain but
essentially just wielders of the force
for evil reason there you go I would be
on board with that I feel like that
would be fun just it cuz also it opens
the door to like even more things you
could play around with like that like
it's there's even further things out
there and the force acts even stranger
if we go further out and like there's
different aspects ever there we haven't
played with yet that'd be kind of fun
there was one other idea where to say
and if it maybe if he did you guys ever
play the insidious games but they are
blanking they were ps4 games where
basically you could choose if you wanted
to be a superhero good or bad
you could end up changing the aplans
well you could do a couple like like in
StarCraft ticket you could play as
different races somewhere that and one
of the Star Wars game basically when you
at the end of the game at the end of the
second game you got to make a decision
of like do we get rid of all powered
people or do you become the thing to you
oh is that the one well the the famous
ad campaign was when you could play as
Vader in Battlefront yeah and it was
kind of like choose your side basically
yeah but there at the in the finale of
that you were able to choose to wipe out
basically all of the force or whatever
gave people superpowers and I always
thought that was kind of a fun idea
where it's like hey if you kind of set
up in the last Jedi that you kind of
want to get rid of all force things
period that was one of the ideas that
was presented it's like maybe you went
full into it and be honest thing that
could eradicate the use of award which
is an interesting existential threat
that actually would have special stakes
to Star Wars where you know a lot of
people felt like oh these movies have
felt like a repeat of the previous
trilogy and it's like well the dying out
of the Jedi has been done right but what
about the magic that they tap into that
dying out that's kind of interesting
yeah I also could and it could just wrap
up this whole like repeat of the Empire
again there's like it's the same like
you said it's the same thing so bring
them together on a common ground where
they have to work together and then the
galaxy actually moves forward in a
positive direction where they actually
have to figure out how to make this work
you know what I mean but one thing I
really liked about the last Jedi was the
way it explained the force in practical
terms like it's just an energy that
binds everything and there's a light
side and a dark side there's violence
and there's peace and they showed you
know close-ups of like a nest with a
bunch of pores in it and then like
crashing waves and I like that depiction
of the force as opposed to like the
midi-chlorians from the prequels and I
think the more we go down that rabbit
hole and try to explore like the
mysticism of it and create new like
fantasy images and places it gets too
far away from what I think is so great
about the the whole mythology of the
force that George Lucas created in the
first movie it's it's it's this mystical
thing that almost feels like BS that
just feels like kind of a way that
certain
crazy people see the world and by the
end of that movie it's validated and the
way that Luke can hear Obi Wan's voice
from beyond the grave guarding him - or
guiding him to destroy the Death Star
and I think the more we start to pull
that thread the more the tapestry starts
to fall apart so I would hope that these
just stay rumors or the beyond it's just
something else or there's like a
character named the beyond that they've
been working with and that's who they're
coming back from rather than like a form
of heaven and we see what we're ghosts
go yeah I mean even the whole idea of
force ghosts the way that they appeared
in Return of the Jedi kind of threw me a
little bit I'm not I've never been crazy
about like force ghosts coming back
because I just like death being final
and if it's just like Luke kind of
hearing the voice in his head that's
okay to me but if it's - like if it gets
too simple and then Yoda can come back
at any time and talk to anyone at any
time it feels like what are the stakes
of that you know did you ever really
lose them yeah though that said it it
does beg the question as soon as the
force ghosts exist and it's always ready
to go then it's like where do they stay
and lying wait yeah and then is that for
seven I would always like the idea that
they're just in the mind of the
perceiver you know that Luke sees Yoda
or his like connection with the force
allows him to tap into these memories
and those memories have a form of AI of
their own based off of their memories of
their teachings and of their personality
and it's just really that form
manifesting on its own speaking back to
them as opposed to something external I
like the idea that it's in their own
mind and in their person yeah it's kind
of like Kryptonian tech right you know
yeah Superman can have conversations
with his parents but they're not really
there right yeah yeah well we got some
more Star Wars news from Anthony Daniels
who plays c-3po and does the voice of
them in the new movies there's like a
couple tweets that are kind of crazy he
initially tweeted earlier this week that
he had a big announcement he was kind of
acting like he was receiving the
transmission and it's coming and I won't
got excited are we gonna get a title
reveal of episode 9 everyone was pumped
and then he said that the there was some
kind of confusion on the on the
reception and then the last thing he
tweeted was that oh it's coming into act
Lia's coming in t Rav and then kind of
cutoff himself and everyone's like what
the hell does this mean
well the t Rav is is the hinting at what
the title of the movie could be because
one thing that people realize is that
all Star Wars movies all the titles have
begun with the letter T the letter R the
letter A like the previous seven that
have come out I guess if you include
wrote one that works like a soloist Star
Wars stories not working that but if you
consider than the main chapters of the
Star Wars movies they're all T or RA so
does that mean V will be the first
letter of the title of episode nine yeah
it does seem like he was in the soup for
too long and his brain cooked he's dying
he's tweeting for help he's probably a
life alert mix-up there yeah he looks
like like looks like if the c-3po suit
was like play-doh cast and he just done
it too many times and now he's starting
to like shape his brain look at it you
can't see I can I can hear the tweets I
can hear the tweets coming in jumbled
tweets ah if it were a V though y'all
got pictures V names Vader legacy Vader
returns Vader ain't done
Vader's back we get evaders we sorry we
could that Vedas there's t Rav
somebody were saying T Rav could be the
the letters of the words of it so like
or maybe it's in a phrase that he's
saying like T Rav could be like title
reveal after Valentine's Day so or title
says they were fitted to the title like
the revenge it's a good title yeah but I
don't think it is a title reveal if some
people are even thinking it's just as
simple I was like really seeing the
movies in 4k
and there's this some really convoluted
way of announcing that I think it is
something maybe more in that direction a
little further away from title revealer
trailer but I also I'm telling you is
it's like someone check on this guy like
like they don't make any sense any of
these tweets with themselves maybe he's
just it's a joke that all become clear
later like travel t'as gonna be in it or
travel star wars cruises and it's a Star
Wars fan cruise because they do that for
back to the future they do that for Star
Trek it's definitely a Star Wars cruise
boom tiny we hooked rabbits ain't
variates
oh that's good these are good ideas yeah
well we solved it it won't do bugs well
let us know in the comments below what
you think that you're a be my old man
these sweets could be referring to but
some other stuff came out this week Sam
what have you heard may I please thank
you and I'm excited let's talk about in
other news Chris Pratt handsome man
confirms the guardians of galaxy 3 will
use James Gunn's
script that's been it's been the word
around town and good to get a little
confirmation confirm like third time in
a row we also know that we also know
that the epics show
pennyworth the Batman prequel about
Alfred his Butler will apparently be an
quote unhinged r-rated series set in the
1960s and featuring a descendant of Jack
the Ripper as its main antagonist or at
least as far as we know and also will
not feature any Batman villains right
now Jake the Ripper also there's a rumor
that Avengers endgame could have a
runtime of three whole hours maybe
longer there was even a little rumor of
an intermission which yes please I need
to pee I pee every 15 minutes I was like
check-in on like Scarlet Witch and it's
like there's like a little message you
can go to the bathroom or there's like
sand from from an hourglass but it looks
like the dust of the dead people
cool also Robert Pattinson is reportedly
being considered to replace Ben Affleck
[ __ ] in Matt Reeves the Batman oh man
I really like my audio listeners loved
this story the baton Batman Jason yes
yeah yeah no I'm really on board with
this he's gotten a lot of amazing roles
velocity is Ed good times I'm 100
percent over dickory there you go mmm
Twilight very good well so finally a
first one was okay and Taika Waititi
will not be directing guardians 3 saying
this is his quote going into something
like that which has got which got his
stamp all over it would feel like going
to someone someone's house and go and
pay mom your new dad and this is how we
make peanut butter sandwiches now it
just feels kind of awkward yeah
interesting response cuz that's like you
know it's James Gunn's baby and we would
want Tyco with teetee he seems like the
best person to take it over and I think
it's just people are like Oh a more
funny Marvel director and so they wanted
to did a funny space movie that's
colorful which to me is a great reason
to not have him do that you know I mean
like he's got his let him do his I get I
get the appeal but I'm glad that he you
know put a stamp on he's like now I'm
not going to be doing that I'm gonna be
making what we do in the shadows TV
series which I'm very excited about what
I'm also excited for is our lightning
round because they never got any good
questions before we get to that we have
one more announcer that we want to give
all guys so we mentioned The Walking
Dead earlier we will actually be
resuming our coverage of The Walking
Dead but he didn't write down so we had
to stop at the begin of season 9 just
there was a lot of reasons why at the
end of the day we just couldn't really
afford to do it we had a lot of other
things just straight up we were losing
money we were on those and it was just
killing it was it was and the great news
is there's a streaming service called
Philo who reached out to us and they're
like look we're gonna hook you guys up
we want to sponsor you to keep doing
these breakdowns and they are a great
streaming service they have AMC content
as well as like a ton of other like 50
different channels if like Comedy
Central and MTV Nickelodeon it's like
all the things that like if you are
cutting the cord and you're just trying
to live off of different like streaming
services I feel like the
ones that aren't covered by anything
Philo covers so now you can like finally
completely cut the cord you have to deal
with a stupid cable package that you've
been dealing with you can just go
through Philo and they you can save as
much as like as much as you want there's
no limits on how much you save and you
can go back and catch up on
better call Saul The Walking Dead The
Comedy Central shows it's it's awesome
in there they're helping us out with ya
dead breakdowns we'll put a link here
for signing up if you're interested on
getting AMC and all these other channels
streaming if you use our service I think
they're doing the week for free or
something but if you use our link follow
that link Philo thank you so much for
bringing back our walking dead right now
and I think is will be real excited on
Monday after the season 9 premiere which
airs Sunday on AMC on Monday we will
have our breakdown and review and
in-depth analysis and it's season 9s if
you guys been keeping up with these men
it's been a lot better and like a step
forward like the whispers are now part
of the show like there's been a new
showrunner and like it it's really like
been in a better position these past
nine episodes and I'm glad we get to
talk about it again and hopefully you
guys hopefully this break down series
will do well because we'd love to keep
doing this for all of season 9 for
what's left but now yeah let's move on
to the lightning round
somebody create a theme song for cymbals
maybe is a lightning round
alright Sam that's wat amar do you think
huh and homage to Stanley on future at
Marvel movies should be done through CGI
like Leia or like the way they did it in
Deadpool with the graffiti or a poster
or maybe even a clever name drop do you
know a real clever name drop yeah
Deadpool do a picture don't please don't
do that to that poor man no no no I like
the name drop was just a guy named
Stanley arrestees Jonte what's your
favorite end game Pam theory going
around at the moment who my favorite fan
theory going around is the craziest one
I think that Loki turn himself into the
Hulk and that look he's still alive
that's that's I think it's continues to
be the craziest one
and it's my favorite and will always be
the favorite and then there's no way
it's gonna be correct when it comes out
it's so funny if he's like Santos J
black.if while in Westeros you had to
choose the champion to fight in your
place and a trial by combat who would
you choose and why I mean it's obvious
that it should be shocking agar cuz he
doesn't lose those things but I'm still
gonna say the Viper
yeah he's such a fun fighter and it is
such a satisfying pop same as HP d
reckon Theon will sacrifice himself to
save his sister Yara and if so do you
think this will be a quote good ending
for him it will I have been tired of his
character for a hot minute so I hope
that's how it goes hope sister ends up
okay and I you know what yes it'll be a
fine ending for him redemption story yes
redemption song Erik at Ft velocity do
you think the Green Dragon class that
John saw and hardhome will play a part
in hardhome um I think they left
everything in hardhome behind that's an
interesting theory but I don't think
it'll play a part yeah though not saying
that dragonglass won't play dragonglass
course will part that particular Phillip
at malice hedgehog what are the chances
that Ned Stark is still actually John's
dad gross yeah Sam as so not likely Sam
at screenplay who is the best fighter in
Game of Thrones living or dead yet but
well the mountain scorn true scorn other
than dragons what mythical beast would
you like to see brought to life on Game
of Thrones yeah something crazy I see
lions Erik all surreal yeah at Santa's
dove do you think baby Sam being the
brother of so many White Walkers could
possibly turn into one oh it's Annie
already oh oh oh oh baby baby oh his
that I think that will be a threat I
think that baby will get taken by white
walkers at some point here I'm gonna put
out there but I don't think he'll turn
into one but that will be like a quest
that the characters have to go under to
make sure that baby doesn't get turned
away I like that you kind of made this
not like it's the babies choice he
decides cases
okay everybody at underpants gnome if
IKEA made the Iron Throne what would
they call it swore gin chair it's okay
sweets on the Swedish let's go with
Lauren
thanks for saying there's questions but
now comes the time for a 15-second shout
out enjoys days 15 seconds to shout out
ramble plug anything we want Sam you got
something yes for podcast listeners
thank you for joining us on the himalaya
appreciate it but you can also check out
david tennant does a podcast with
thought thought thought and then he
brings on a guest and they are
delightful out of celebrities bringing
on other celebrities to talk about
celebrity things that has been the most
delightful list and so far listen to it
philip uh what am i into right now the
brilliant lights which i look it up it's
called brilliant it's a cool light
switch replacement brilliant light
switch I'm not being paid by them
brilliant you should be for my fifty
seconds thank you all two who came out
to our first darkest night Philip was
there and Maude and Tommy were there too
six out of ten sure will hopefully be
there it was a lot of fun and we'll do
that every first Friday the month for
next Friday the 15th I'll be doing a
sketch show with my sketch team dad
jeans at that theater it'll be a whole
different type of thing we're doing
different material you'll good to see me
act actually it's gonna be a really
funny show so if you're in the LA area
come check that out just come to the
Acme theatre every Friday night there's
always good stuff there great so let's
return to our trivia question that we
asked earlier
we now know what the answer is a loser
as decided by our judges will have to
join the the gif of shame society to
real Assad caste remember to check out
and follow us on our social so you can
see our shameful gifts yes yes yes to
remind everyone of what the question was
Thanos is the short form of the Greek
word Thanatos wins what we said Sam says
death to the heart power keep a little
heart no the heart reaches tree you feel
Oh
Phillips says destroyer no and Eric says
conqueror well the correct answer was
death meaning Samm is Samm how did you
know that did you take Greek any point
Venture Brothers venture brothers taught
me that thanks Venture Brothers and then
judges his closer destroyer Conqueror II
D so that means I am safe this week
finally and Eric loses so that's me I'm
Eric so here's what's gonna happen I'm
gonna do one of these goofy things and
then Sam's gonna read our goodbyes so
here's what I have to do and Avengers in
game trailer just dropped but your
computer is buffering Oh ain't that been
another session before okay so I'm gonna
do that just right here let's clear the
screen for him if you're listening eric
is getting ready to a full stream this
is my favorite part of the podcast I'll
tell you what this is this is pretty fun
yes don't worry you can go ahead and
check out at new rock stars on Twitter
to make sure you watch all of the
hilarity ensued but you know what gig
let's say thank you for watching or
listening to this week's episode of new
rockstars news I want to thank our host
me up top at Sam basher cuz I'm the
winner I get first place the Phillip
Molina at fimo and Eric Foss at EA vos
remember that this is also available in
audio form and video form videos at
youtube.com slash new rock stars and get
the audio anywhere you get your podcast
but if you use the Himalaya app you can
actually leave a comment on the podcast
and it supports so directly love
come and tweet us at new rock stars like
I said previously like this video and
podcast share it around and subscribe to
rock stars for deep dives into the stuff
you love
see you next week goodbye mmm good bye
bye yeah well I was not watching sorry
didn't Syd look like it was father he
liked it here